we are still here at the scene of this
terrible disaster caused by a massive
tornado which swept through sector zero
one and two
amidst the wreckage of the expressway
search and rescue operations are already
in progress
[Music]
wow
just look at it all it's so green even
after everything we've done to it it's
still going strong it may look that way
barely hanging on
I was wondering what's Cloud been doing
these past five years where's he been
and you're asking me this
this is gonna sound crazy but as far as
I know
Cloud was never in miebelheim five years
ago
live stream
it is the very essence of our star
blood coursing through its planetary
veins
according to Hojo they're connected to
sephiroth
Shadows of the man I believe he called
them
sephiroth was in midgar we fought him
whatever happened he's alive but why
come back now
after five years doing who
knows
well now I think we woke it up
angered it more like
Feast your eyes on the Turks latest and
greatest Elena she may be new
turkey
together
foreign
they say she's a monster that she can
pure inside you into the very depths of
your soul
that she can become those you hate those
you fear
those you love
green and
murdered my dad
you burned my Village
do you know that I killed her
so who is she
[Music]